today we're here with Matt we're going
to be talking about the top 10 actors
Amazon want to return to any new
Stargate franchise and we've got a
little bit of a surprise
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
that's it we are rebranding the channel
uh if you've even changed the logo at
the top Corner well done we are
Matt has been working really hard on
this new design and it's actually going
on The Branding everything there as well
so SCI dashtrack.com you can get this
new design it looks so good on the hat
mate honestly like a beanie and a
baseball cap it looks amazing I've
ordered myself too
um I tell you what as well I am going to
be giving a little bit of a giveaway in
the new year with some of this branded
stuff and a couple of other stargatey
things when I get around to it
um but you know I thought that would be
a nice little cheer us up in the dull
gray months of January but um we'll come
back to that in a little while but for
now we're not really here about the
rebranding
because we got this list from one of my
sources of starting the Stargate
because we got this list from one of my
sources at Amazon
and
they've been I've done two videos on it
I've told you what the two two top names
on this list were but just to give a
quick rundown
um Amazon uh have done a bit of research
and they've
done this algorithm or whatever and
they've decided what the top 10 people
that they would like to bring back to a
new Stargate franchise if possible and
not necessarily who they'd like to bring
back but who would have the most impact
if they did return to the Stargate
franchise a little bit of um add on to
this actually because I asked why wasn't
Jason Momoa like top because he's like
the biggest star one of the biggest
stars in Hollywood at the moment and
it's apparently they do include
something in there that's sort of like
um gives them How likely it is that they
would actually return if that makes
sense so they sort of factor in like
he's way too famous so it knocked him
down the list a little bit
[Music]
oh wouldn't it be cool man and he does
devise I I think if they did like a
one-off streaming series
I think he could I think they could talk
him into it
he did see apple we spoke about
other series is that we could
potentially see from a Stargate a series
based on um Ronan decks as a runner like
before Stargate Atlantis would be
fantastic and he'd
is
he he would be good I wanted to come
back yes it'd be so cool wouldn't it
even if you're going back just for a
couple of episodes like a big special
double episode sort of thing at the end
of the series or something like that
would be really cool but anyway
top of the list for me absolutely no
shock at all was Richard Dean Anderson
um so that's the video I did a couple of
days ago talking about receiving
Anderson now I don't think it doesn't
really say on this whether they would
come back as cameos or whether they
would come back as returning actors
I can't see Richard Dean Anderson coming
back as a regular what do what do you
think
I can
see both ways
the original reason he left was so he
could spend more time with his family do
his charity work etc
um nowadays you might have a little bit
more time so he could be a reoccurring
character but not a massive character so
kind of like General Hammond for example
he could be that kind of character where
he's in it pretty much every episode he
doesn't really do much
yeah
yeah
a massive time effort as well doesn't it
could basically come on for a few days
every few weeks sort of thing and do a
bit of filming and it's so it's a
recurring character but like you said
yeah it's not a major character
um
my thinking with any of the SG-1 team if
they come back I mean I'm going with you
think about how they would do it for me
it's I think it's really easy they've
got a new team and they go through and
they come across a problem the sg1
encountered back in the day so they
almost have to like bring sg1 back as
much like Consultants or something I
think that would be a really easy way to
bring back the entire team and I
actually think they could bring back all
of the original sg1
practice Yeah really easily and they do
it you can easily bring them all back if
only for one episode they could all they
could all it could be like the big
moment where they all like reunite like
it could be a
we have we have Jack in one episode Sam
in another episode Daniel in another and
then tilk and then towards the end of
the season they they form together and
SG-1 is back for that one for hurray
kind of thing yeah yeah and then that
launches into and that gives us a chance
as well to get to know the new team and
the new actors that they would bring in
and then we launch into the new
franchise the new projects I think so a
nice wave goodbye to what was
and then it bleeds or anything but
anyway the second person on the list was
a complete shock to me and I and I don't
really get it and I do I'd love to know
what your opinion is but it was it's
Robert Carlisle from msgu so the Rush
character from Stargate Universe
I I don't get it
any any ideas I don't get it
there's a massive mate and he was a big
name
before but that's the whole reason they
got him for Stark at Universe because he
was a big name and he wanted to kind of
have
a bigger show with Stargate Universe I
don't know it didn't go that way in the
end but
yeah he's still a big name
people who like call Monty things like
that who have seen him in in the past
might come back because they go oh what
Carlisle's in this and then that it
might be like that we've talked about
cross-pollination with audiences before
having a big actor
even though he was involved in his
Target before people may not know he was
involved I think and bring people back
in
and obviously if it is and I say I don't
know how they spat him out a second in
the algorithm I don't know how that
happened but we don't know 100 what
their criteria was before this but um I
mean if they if they basically think the
one thing is the um the Eli characters
David blue
um
he has got some he's quite a strict
conservative and he's got some point
I'm serious like um
political views which might think and
I'm wondering if there's something in
the algorithm that's sort of like
filtered out negative
comments and messages and sort of thing
oh there's some some reason because I
will say now he doesn't appear on the
top 10 list at all
David Blaine that's surprising that's
very surprising yeah but if they've put
something in the algorithm and say that
we want somebody from SGU
um and David Blues knocked out because
of other things because I say I don't
know how to fix it I also don't know how
much human interaction there was in this
and whether they've done an algorithm
they've gone you know what we're
spitting David blew out because of this
or because of that I actually but I
actually think from a story point of
view if you're gonna because if Rush is
in it then the obvious thing is that the
women's were going to save the crew from
SGU
yeah or at least some of them
if David blue doesn't survive they kind
of if Eli doesn't survive they kind of
had to explain that didn't they because
he's the one that's left awake
how do you do that
he's the easiest one I think to kill off
because he was the only one left awake
something happens for the destiny he
dies they're all still in cryo exactly
but as fans
I think there was always a team Rush
team Eli kind of thing going on with
with SGU
I'm not sure the team Rush side was
bigger than the team Eli side I love
Rush don't get me wrong it was a very
interesting character yeah I prefer
delay
so I'm very surprised it's not even on
the list at all I would put if I if I
was to rejig the list
Richard didn't answered obviously at the
Top If if we put Robert Carlo on second
David blue has to be third because it's
rush and Eli they come they come as a
pet
yeah well we'll rejig the list at the
end I think if you're up for it we'll
we'll we'll we'll do the list what we
think would have done but I tell you
what who stood on the list I think for
me is obvious and I'm surprised she's
not second is Amanda Tapping
[Music]
um
she's always talking about Stargate
she's obviously very active still as a
director and a producer
um she goes to all the conventions and
things and
um I mean Brad Wright talks about it so
much about how he would like to bring
her back and that we would see General
Carter so if we were going to see Brad
Wright's version of Stargate we would
see him under tapping she she would
return
um I think that's an easy one in it
she's a fat he's a she's a fan favorite
her and Jack
we want to see one of them at least
because we want to know if they got
together or not and what and even if
it's only one of them we'll get that
answer
yeah and and for me I think they should
do it the way Brad Wright was talking
about doing it or just having like a
little throwaway line like right
apparently the line was going to be I've
still got your toothbrush
um Jack to Sam when they sort of came
face to face so like that they were
together but they'd split up and so I
mean I think that gives you a lot of
with one line there I've still got your
toothbrush sort of gives you
a big video of a lot of information it
was like you know like how long ago was
it did they only just put what what tell
me more
oh there's like yeah it's so teasing
isn't it well but at the same time tells
you so much fourth on this is again it
was one that I I'm not even remotely
surprised by Miss Michael shanks
um the only thing I think they might
struggle getting him back is I he's on
um I think it's Chicago Hope or another
doctor TV show in America when I don't
watch
um I I think he's a regular returning
character and I don't know what sort of
contract he signed for that and if
they're filming this this year
getting Michael Shanks back from more
than one or two episodes might be
difficult
but he's all probably about to do a
guest appearance at least yeah unless he
can get out of the other contract and
come back to Stargate he's always said
he'd come back he talks about it all the
time
um he probably tried to bring his wife
with her I'm not going to try and say
her name I think it's Alexa doig but I
don't really know how to pronounce it
oh uh Beau Bridges is
um character's daughter
yeah yeah she was a doctor but um and
she was also an Andromeda and a few
other things she's unlinkly beautiful
but like so we'll call Alexa
um I'll probably just set off my um my
listening devices I just had to look
over there to make sure
um
and there's also rumors that he would
come and and direct as well that that
would be that again if it was Brad
Wright's project that's what they'd used
to tease him in so we don't just want
you on the screen we want you behind the
screen
um
he could bring so much to the show as
well obviously being part of it so if he
was only behind the camera he's got all
of the experience of being on the camera
and all of the stories that come before
it so let's let's assume
let's for example say whoever wrote an
episode didn't get something right he
could be the guy like no actually you've
got to do it like this he could be the
consultant
yeah if you're not going to bring in
Brad writer something like that as a
consultant he's the one for me I think
Michael Shanks is the one that I would
like to have seen come back as a regular
when we said we we did our little SGC
project or we we thought about the first
five or six seasons of of what Stargate
would look like if we brought it back we
sort of made him the
um a new head of the SGC the you know
like the non-military the civilian head
of the SGC then that now the SGC was
um's Target command was known everybody
knew about it so there was a civilian
node recycling so I I for me he's the
easiest to bring back as a regular
he's the most obvious choice for being
head of a civilian-led Stargate program
because he was always
the voice of reason within the military
branch
so now it's outside if it was outside of
the military it makes sense for him or
some very much like him to be in charge
exactly yeah and I'd like to say any is
one of the most likable actors I think
and one of the most likable characters
came in and replaced Daniel he was a
local actor as well and I thought they
did a really good job replacing him but
he was not Daniel
and you know none of us were upset when
he went really
I wanted to see more of Jonas I would
have liked it if he played more of a
reoccurring role and didn't just leave
the show entirely but I think he did
have something else in the pipeline as
he left so that's why he never came back
yeah and he did one or two little guest
episodes didn't know what that was it
fifth on the list
is Jason Momoa
um he is one of those actors that he's
brilliant in everything he does have you
seen the Netflix film he did the
Christmas film he did yet
[Music]
um you can watch it with the kids it's
it's brilliant it's really really good
and he is fantastic and he plays more of
a comic sort of role
um and he's going but I knew in Stargate
Atlantis that he would be a big star you
just you just knew it you could tell he
had like The Cheeky green and everything
and
um
like he is action star like physique
like you just knew he was going to do
big great things yeah I mean he did that
so that's not that great but he does
some other great things
as well that Conan movie The only thing
the only problem with that Conan movie
it wasn't a bad film but they made him
shave his beard off and he'd look stupid
one of my favorite things he's done
there's an advert for something I can't
remember what the advert is it's like oh
when I go home I want to just relax and
he's taken off his muscles he takes off
his hair
sixth on the list actually was another
actor again that if I'm doing this list
I'm putting him higher up
David Hewlett
oh David Hewlett would be top for me for
sure McKay
was I mean from two points I like to
think about this like if I was the
producer How likely is it we could get
him back and how easy and believable it
is it to write him into the story right
so a lot we got a lot of comments and I
go no no no we've just got to have this
guy and this guy and that's just based
on like who you like who you want to see
but um I'm like think I'm always
thinking like if I was actually writing
this how easy would it be David Hewlett
would do it in a second
McKay is just a brilliant lovable
character which we all kind of love to
hate at times but he's just he's just
brilliant and it would be really really
easy to write in
yeah he's one of those characters who
always wants to be involved like even
when he's not like invited he'll make
himself involved and I feel like in a
new
a new version of Stargate he would just
be there and no one invited him but he's
there
and obviously then that would bring in
Atlantis I would get to see Atlantis
again potentially because again that's a
really easy way to bring Atlantis back
into this new Stargate project and like
I said he's as uh for me as a writer
if I was ever going to write the show
he's just a dream character to
um as you know to bounce people off
um
that guy uh what's his name
zelenski the his real name is David
something
I'd like him to come back if they
brought back McKay because they're there
to chemistry together was really
number seven on the list I don't know I
put a three up number seven on the list
um actually related to David Ewell it
would be
um Joe Flanagan and bring him back
Shepard
um again
for me this is a no-brainer and I mean
particularly because he's so good at
bouncing off characters he hasn't
particularly aged that badly he still
looks good
he's a he is a massive Stargate fan we
know how much was Target fan is it
because he tried to bite it
um you know it's
for me is is easy you know and I'm and I
could see that I reckon he'd do it in a
heartbeat like as soon as the new
Stargate came out even if they didn't
ask him he would ask
yeah yeah I could see him being like at
the studio door sort of like go let me
in it's like you're not in this like
[ __ ] I am I'll be in the background
it's like a
Daniel Craig doing storms you know being
dressed up as a stormtrooper just
because he desperately wanted to be in
Star Wars I could see Joe Flanagan has
been inhaling her is that you're funny
no
um this was really a surprise to me
though because eighth on the list hey
eighth on the list was Christopher
judged
laughs
foreign
this one though now really shocked me
right because eighth on the list eight
was Christopher Judge
do we really think that the eighth most
least important or the I mean ain't to
bring tioch back
it's in Madness
tilt needs to come tilt would be in my
my top five
they wouldn't be eighth it wouldn't be
fifth either he'd be in the top five but
he wouldn't be fifth he'd be
up there of course who do you scratch
out though that's the I suppose the
problem is uh who do you get rid of but
we we can do we can play that game at
the end again though again from a
writer's point of view how easy is it
bring to your back it's just it's a
piece of piss
you know you could he could literally
just be in a one episode and it could be
something to do with the Jafar or the
Freedia Foundation maybe there's a new a
new
um
offshoot of the Jafari Nation and that
they're they're slightly evil kind of
like the Lucian Alliance but they have
to kind of get into the heart the High
Council and who's in the top of the High
Council it's tilk
I think an easy way to bring the Jafar
back then if you had if you had a
fraction of the faction of the Jafar
that were a problem it's just to make
them that they think they should be in
charge and that they're better than
everyone else because they kind of do
and kind of did you know they always
kind of look down on humans isn't it
even even teal could kind of look down
on people you know particularly at first
you seems like I'm proud enough we're
better than you so it wouldn't be a leap
to say that a faction of the Jafar sort
of thought you know what why why the
Towery in charge of everything why
aren't we
something yeah I've got a bit of
Technology than than what we had when we
first started and they probably got
better technology now
they've probably done a lot of research
in the last 10 years
you'd think so wouldn't you
um well ninth on the list we're smashing
through it
um Ben Browder came in at number nine
so
Mitchell Crowder
powder prouder powder prouder yeah
proudly
Baba
if I just go I love that then and then
nobody can even but anyway Mitchell
so if Mitch saw to come back he's he's a
bit like Joe Flanagan for me he doesn't
really look that much different
um he's he got I mean he appeared in a
couple of the Guardians of the Galaxy
movies dressed as a gold dude
he could walk straight back into this
and it wouldn't it'd be like
but I'm gonna have to look this up
right so I've got anything else you know
the gold lot that are attacking the
Guardians
and there's the gold chick who's in
charge
is the number two it's like here Colonel
sort of thing oh my God it looks exactly
the same except he's cool
this is gold
um
number 10 on the list though man is an
actor that I adore and I wanted to go to
a Sci-Fi convention this year
um just because this guy was doing
um photo ops and so you could have a
picture with them and they they even had
um James T Cook or William Shatner
himself and then they're going now now I
want to go see the other guy
Robert picardo
and oh yeah I just love Robert picardo
he is the doctor as far as I'm concerned
I know you're going to go he's Doctor
Who now he's the doctor
um and and his character in um in
Stargate Atlantis was great as well and
actually if he came back
I follow him on Facebook though this
guy's screw loose he's getting something
wrong with him it's he's gloriously
mental
but um I'd love to see him come back as
well going back to when we were talking
about Michael Shanks and potentially
being in charge of the SGC
um always no sorry scrap that going back
to when we were talking about
um like Richard Dean Anson and that
coming back in as reoccurring roles
I would picture as Rich D Nancy coming
in as a Woolsey type character if not
General Hammond so he can come in like
whenever
but
it'll be reoccurring in the sense that
he's definitely a character but he's
just not there all the time yeah like
Woolsey was
a bit strong enough to be a regular
was in in Stargate for like what
40 episodes Maybe well
sg1 a handful of times but then towards
the end of Atlantis he was pretty much
in every week honey
in charge for the last couple of Seasons
yeah so um yeah 40 episodes is probably
about right but but yeah he was a
regular by the end but um but yeah I'm
with you that I think as a as a as an
extra
character circling he'd be great
um
and like I just love it as an actor I
just love him I'd have I didn't look I'm
saying I'm just I'm gonna have to go to
the next Convention of these there
because I desperately want a photo with
him I have messaged him to try and get
him on the channel and he never replied
to me but I'd love to have had Robert
glider on this channel kind of killed
for it but if I might try again at
something that would have been very good
yeah
so that's the list that's the top ten so
it's Richard Dean Anderson Robert
Carlisle Amanda Tapping Michael Shanks
Jason Momoa David's Hewlett Joe Flanagan
Christopher Judge Ben bowdler
and Robert picardo is there anybody on
that list first of all that you wouldn't
have on there
that I wouldn't have on there um
you just say the list again
Richard Dean Anderson Robert Carlisle
Amanda Tapping Michael Shanks Jason
Momoa David Hugh let Joe Flanagan
Christopher Judge Ben bowdler Robert
picardo
we probably wouldn't have bambrada in
there
yeah because he wasn't I I loved Cameron
Mitchell
but
he wasn't Jack O'Neil
that's the original
do you know the best thing about
Mitchell's character were the jokes they
made about how much he looked like
Daniel
that was the best thing Claudia Black
coming on and going uh that's a very
shallow gene pool isn't it boys and
they're just sort of like look at each
other and that was the best thing about
Mitchell to be honest
um and I liked him I wouldn't have Jason
Momoa on this list
for the not not because I don't want him
to return
I don't think he I don't think he would
I don't think there's enough money to
get him to do it
um
but if he did Christ it would be awesome
but it would be no more than an episode
you know I don't know if he did yeah it
would be amazing but um I'll tell you
what I'm not gonna say I'm gonna scuff
him off the list but I'm saying if I had
to going against the head I would go
with Ben bowdo as well
um as well and I would go but if I had
to pick a second one it would be
Jason Momoa just because I don't think
because of what I said
do you know what though
if I'd have done my own top 10 without
seeing this I don't think Robert Carlyle
would have been on it
I really don't
think I would have picked him I wouldn't
have picked him but
knowing he's on the list I would keep
him on there
yeah I I think I would have swapped him
for David blue and he would be a lot
further down the list for me
I would bring back Eli
um if we would if we were going to
remove a couple and add a couple
I would remove uh my I'd remove Ben
Browder and I would add in
um
I've just had the name in my head uh
valderram Claudia Black I'd had her have
her in and I'd add in David blue
yeah
I did love Claudia Black's character and
to be fair
if you've got Daniel
how much do you want to see him and
um I can't remember the character's name
father father
um but yeah if you've got to have if
you've got Daniel Jackson in there how
much do you want Valor as his partner
you know um no matter because I mean
that was just that was that was again
some of the best bits of series nine and
ten was them two bouncing off each other
they were fantastic but yeah in the
final episode
but obviously that timeline didn't exist
so
we're starting to get together in the
current timeline in reality yeah I think
I would for me
David Hewlett would be originally
Langston topless to me I would kill to
see Richard Dean Anderson [ __ ]
Stargate
I I just love it um he's lost loads of
weight it'd look better than he did
um at the start of SGU to be honest
um
he's top of the list to me and I'm not
having you argue and if you can try and
argue if you want but I'll just delete
you from the video
and um just nobody it'll be number one
for me as well good good boy good boy
Michael Shanks number two
yes it's David Hewlett for me
but
for two reasons I love him dearly and I
think he's the easiest one to get in
I think he would I think you'd have to
actually if you told him he couldn't I
think he would probably try to punch you
in the face and and run over you and he
said no all you'd have to do is just
just go would you like to and by the
time you've got the sentence he'd be at
the studio but I just think he could do
so much for this character
that's that's for me but um but if they
had Daniel I wouldn't argue either
yeah
I mean my third isn't David Hewlett he's
my fourth my third would be Amanda
Tapping
it's hard not to want General Carter in
it
it's really hard not to want that very
badly
but you know what I would rather
I think I'd rather have Valor
but Valor is not a wholly popular
character within the fandom I guarantee
you there will be comments going oh
God's sake not uh she was awful but I
didn't know and I loved it I thought she
was great I thought she was so funny
is not just a good leader
um a good character she's also like one
of the most intelligent people in the
franchise so anytime something happens
who are they gonna call Sam Carter
yeah that is right I mean what you're
gonna do if you've got a star to blow up
you're not gonna call Valor
but yeah I I don't think the list
they've got
that Amazon have put together here
um or their marketing department has put
together here is is ridiculous to be
honest there's nobody on there that I
think what the hell is that that person
doing on there that's just stupid
um I I question Robert Carlisle in
second more because I just don't know
how they got there I just don't know
they I don't know that I think it would
be based on popularity and because he's
a big name that's why he's number two
but saying that why is Jason Momoa not
third
yeah unless they've gone unless
basically they've already got a rough
idea what the story is going to be in
this first season it's going to do with
SGU so they've gone we want an SGU
character which one would have the most
impact which would you know we don't
know we don't know how much like I said
in human influence I mean somebody like
Mark Fergus could have come in on I want
actually a character that's going to
stir things up who would be the best
person to bring in
complicated
but um yes that's interesting but there
could be like a trial for Rush like they
finally getting back and they put him on
trial because he literally put all those
people's lives in danger he killed that
Senator essentially
yeah so he's he's liable for that
see that's a whole that's a whole can of
worms I didn't even thought about you
you know
the only one I'm a little book a
football by though is Christopher Judge
in Haines
because he would be really easy to bring
back he's really easy to tell a story
about and to get into the story we know
he'd be up for it I don't know of any
political or anything like that issues
with him
um
the only thing I could see potentially
being an issue is if he gets the the gig
at God of War
which I don't think he will
now there's a massive petitions for him
to do it and he said he wants to do it
whether they'll listen or not is another
thing and if he does that means he can't
really do Stargate so we're kind of
hoping he doesn't get it just so we can
do Stargate but also he is he is Kratos
so yeah he is and another way they could
maybe do to the CGI the character and do
as a voiceover
Maybe
I don't know but then ah it would be
very cool if you got it but then if he
gets out again like he said it'd be very
difficult to get him to start again but
that is our list we have a nice New
branding a nice new logo we have um all
new designs coming up and some brilliant
starting little sequences to the
different videos we've got you've put a
lot of hard work into that Matty sir
um and I've done it in ways I don't even
understand so well done and thank you
sir publicly thank you so much because
they look great they really look great
I've actually pushed doing this video
forwards because I've got a couple of
videos coming up and I really want to
use the starting sequence on so so we've
sort of pushed this ahead a little bit
more than we wanted to but
I think
Merry Christmas I hope you have a Happy
New Year and let's hope for some really
cool stuff in 2023
you do and to everyone watching have a
good day
Happy New Year
[Laughter]
bye-bye Matt
[Music]